[Music]
so surprise some unsuspecting followers
by leaving a positive comment living
your best life Kaelin living your best
life resuming that oh my gosh I love
that reaction of it over and starting
her spread the love campaign for old
magazine meanwhile we would like to
spread some birthday love her way
because lady Oh turned 65 today happy
birthday Oprah and she is celebrating
and true
Oprah fashion everyone guess why guess
what we've got some big big news oh it's
big how better to celebrate Lady Oh
turning 65 and a party with her our
nischelle Turner is taking you along for
the trip of a lifetime I'm on a plane
I'm headed to Florida and I'm about to
join Oprah and Gayle on their
girlfriends getaway cruise I don't it's
insane right and listen to this et is
the only television show that's been
invited to port so we've done it all all
of it a luxury ship pristine white
beaches we will share every moment of
the girlfriends getaway because well
Oprah has been our girlfriend forever I
believe in living the moment and so I'm
so excited about you know getting on et
and starting on Thursday I'm gonna bring
you all of the crazy big fun moments
from the cruise with Oprah and Gayle
this is going to be bananas I can't wait
for this I will see you guys soon
Oprah and Gayle ladies get ready I'm
coming for you oh my gosh
[Music]